[Music]  Wrestlemania wedding bells  John Cena proposed a longtime girlfriend  Nikki Bella  during WrestleMania 33 on Sunday night I  have been waiting so long to ask you  this Stephanie Nicole Garcia colas would  you marry me  and check out that sparkler the pair has  been dating since 2012 and their  relationship has been a major focus on  the reality show total divas it's a fun  ride ET was with John just days ago he  said he wants Nikki by his side when he  turns 40 later this month and that's a  big one for me when I turn 40 I'll  actually you know I will be doing  something that I really would would want  to be doing on my 40th birthday and  that's keep this wonderful ride going  yeah Atlanta filming a movie called  cracked hopefully see my lady on that  day I really would like to see her so  she'll come on in and say hello  [Music]  you